el cargamento que llegó este jueves a
brasil comprende 55 millones de dosis de
la vacuna china coronaba que de ese
total 2,1 millones de inyecciones están
listas para ser aplicadas los 34
millones restantes son insumos para
preparar la vacuna en las instalaciones
del instituto de investigación butantán
con esta llegada estaremos listos y
tendremos alrededor de 9 millones de
vacunas disponibles en el butantán que
pueden ser usadas en la mitad de enero
para iniciar la campaña de inmunización
masiva
brasil es el primer país en completar un
ensayo a gran escala con esta vacuna
desarrollada por el laboratorio sinovac
biotech sin embargo los resultados que
iban a ser publicados a principios de
diciembre incluían la eficacia del
fármaco aún no han salido a la luz pese
a ello las autoridades de sao paulo
confirmaron que el plan de inmunización
en ese estado iniciará en enero
producción 223 de los cines está
apuntando a la producción de la dosis se
está llevando a cabo aquí en la planta
del instituto butantán fundó su programa
estatua y comenzaremos nuestro programa
de inmunización del estado de sao paulo
del 25 de enero es a pesar de esa
relación a pesar de que nos estén
divulgando los valores específicos de la
eficacia sea específicos
la semana pasada del tribunal supremo de
brasil avaló unánimemente que la
vacunación sea obligatoria y que las
autoridades locales pueden sancionar a
quienes decidan no inmunizarse para el
presidente ayr bolsonaro aseguró que su
gobierno no tomara medidas coercitivas
para quienes no acaten la decisión al
tiempo que destacó que no hay prisa por
iniciar las inoculaciones pues la
pandemia está cerca de su fin